und im missbrauchs und
vertuschungsskandal um einen deutschen
privaten der im vatikan unter papst
benedikt dem sechzehnten tätig war gibt
es neue details der geistliche soll zwei
priester zu gewalt sex gezwungen haben
der prälat streitet alles ab
jedoch bischof franke bestätigt nun die
vorwürfe mir nun zugeschaltet ist
bild-reporter nikolaus harbusch
gemeinsam mit alexander stevens dem
anwalt von einem der opfer
warum genau findet die zeugenvernehmung
jetzt nicht vor dem amtsgericht statt
sondern in eichstetten beim bischof
selbst
wir stehen hier vor dem radstädter dom
und jedem jahr ist der rechtsanwalt
das ist ja auch zwei alexander stevens
strafrecht aus münchen
meine kollegen fragt warum stehen wir
hier in eichstätt vom generalvikariat
vor dem amtsgericht als andere sich
sowohl bei dem mutmaßlichen opfer als
auch der mutmaßliche täter um priester
und deswegen ist nicht nur das deutsche
strafrecht anwendbar sondern auch das
kirchliche strafrecht und im rahmen des
geschädigten rechts wurde jetzt ein
vorermittlungsverfahren angesetzt
worum geht es bei diesen sechs kanal im
vatikan bei dem auch engstes umfeld von
papst benedikt betroffen sein soll weil
man dann soll von einem hohenkirchen
bildungsträger sexuell missbraucht
worden sein genauer gesagt sexuell
genötigt mit zungenküsse malträtiert und
sogar bis hin zum körperlicher gewalt an
den geschäftsteilen und das im engsten
umfeld papst benedikt das ganze soll im
apostolischen palast unter anderem
stattgefunden haben unmittelbar in der
wohnung von heute kurz vor der
vernehmung ihres mandanten geben sie
eine pressekonferenz hier vor dem
generalvikariat worum wird dagegen in
erster linie wird es um die
vertuschungsaktionen manch hoher
würdenträger gehen die bis bis zum zug
georgsheim den privaten habe greifen
allerdings soll es natürlich nicht in
erster linie um georg gänswein gehen
sondern vor allem um meine mandanten der
sich einst erhofft nämlich dass sie die
wahrheit zu tage tritt
das ist also eine erwartung heute hat
bild berichtet über den brief den
jemanden bekommen hat von einem
ehemaligen
angestellten von bischof hanke warum
gibt es dafür in dem brief wird einmal
mehr deutlich dass schon seit jahren
nicht nur einfache bürgen träger sondern
wirklich bis in die höchsten rhein alle
in der kirche bescheid wussten dass der
mutmaßliche täter hier entsprechend
agiert dass es regelmäßig zu sexuellen
übergriffen gekommen sein soll
und da kann ich ihnen auch aus meiner
sicht aber auch aus der des mandanten
wirklich sagen dass wir da der bild vor
allem dankbar sind dass hier diese
recherchen angestoßen wurden denn ohne
diesen recherchen werde jetzt vermutlich
auch ein vortrag
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren